last time we introduced the idea of
trigonometry which is all about
measuring triangles and we started
looking at triangles like this with
right angles in them and we said that we
could look at the angles and the sides
in the triangle and see that there were
a relationship so if I call this angle
over here theta this is the side the
longest side in the triangle which is
opposite the right angle so it's the
hypotenuse this side over here is
opposite the angle I'm interested in
sigh call that opposite and then this
one here is next to at the angle that
I'm looking at so this is the adjacent
side we introduced these three ratios we
call them the instead of Trina metric we
abbreviate that to trig the three trig
ratios okay and they were to jog your
memory sine which is opposite on
hypotenuse cos which is adjacent on
hypotenuse and tan which is opposite on
adjacent and then we took the first
letters of all of these different words
and ratios to come up with this mnemonic
device so for sine its sine is opposite
on hypotenuse so Soh opposite aeneas cos
is adjacent on hypotenuse and tan is
opposite on adjacent which is where we
got sohcahtoa from so that's how you
remember what the ratios are but what's
the point why would you actually use
them for so that's what we're gonna
explore now now what I've got here is
just a pair of triangles and I've drawn
the mat with some certain measurements
so here's my ruler and don't want inches
once in a minute okay so what you've got
down here I'm just being approximate I
know it's slightly off but this looks
like it's about eight centimeters and
this one here looks like it's about four
okay now what's interesting is that I
I've drawn this out I if you wanted you
could use Pythagoras to work out what
this side over here is but I'm
interested in not just the sides but the
angles so for instance if you have a
look at this angle in the corner over
here if I place that there I know my
lines are a bit blurry but that looks to
me I read that as approximately 27
degrees okay it's 27 degrees now this is
interesting to me because I wonder if
there are other
was like this so for instance here's
this bigger one if I again do the
measurements so this side over here
that's six centimeters and if I take
this longer side on the bottom that goes
from 1 to 12 so that's at 12 centimeters
okay now if I take this measurement
again what I've got here is that you can
actually see you can make out it forms
the same angle and then you can even see
that this is these triangles look very
much alike it's just this one's bigger
in fact these are similar triangles
everything is in the same proportions
you know for example this bottom side is
twice the length of this one over here
this one is double this one okay and
they're both right-angled so this is
really strange because what I've got
here for the perspective of this 27
degree angle in this triangle I've got
the opposite side and I've got the
adjacent side here okay now we've
learned that one of the trig ratios has
the opposite and adjacent side in it but
oh and a that's for sock Toa
you can see it's this one on the end
it's tan okay so what this is telling us
is that because tan of an angle like say
theta is opposite on adjacent in this
triangle this is saying well theta in
this case it's this angle over here
that's 27 degrees okay it's roughly
equal to I'm saying roughly because all
of these measurements are just
approximate oh it's equal to opposite
that's that's 4 over 8 that's that's the
other side here that's that's about
that's 1/2 ok now this is interesting
when you bring it over here because what
you've got is different lengths like
this is I know it's similar but it's not
the same triangle but the same time you
know this is still from this point of
view this is still the opposite side and
this is still the adjacent side so tan
of 27 degrees again is 6 over 12 so I
should say approximately that's 1/2
still so what we can see here is that
whatever triangle we're in I can draw I
could draw hundreds more which have the
same kind of angle in here the 27
degrees and the
same proportions like so 10:27
is always roughly 1/2 now this is really
fascinating mathematicians know this in
fact you can get a calculator out
you can say 10 27 and you don't get
exactly 1/2 but you get very very close
ok so we can take advantage of this to
work out some different side lengths and
angles ok so for instance if I come back
to this you know I actually used I use a
protractor to measure this out okay
but I can actually see my calculator to
be precise
here's the way I would do it I would say
let's get a new piece of paper here I
would say in that triangle over there
you had 10 of theta equals 4 over 8 it
is about a high which is equal to 1/2
this ratio anyway ok so what you can do
is you can say look I don't want 10 of
theta
I just want theta by itself ok so if you
have a look at your calculator so here's
where the sine cos and tan buttons are
and just about 10 there's a button that
looks like we're just about to turn
butter it's labeled like this 10 and
then there's a negative 1 up there ok
now this is what we call 10 inverse and
we can use it to find out this angle ok
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
say 10 inverse of 10 theta is Theta and
so I'll do 10 inverse of 1/2 okay so if
you're following I can do shift 10 which
will give me 10 inverse and then I put
in 1 over 2 ok now when I press equals
what happens we get twenty six point
five six five six five and so on a whole
bunch of decimals right this is that 27
degree angle that I was trying to
measure out with my protractor but of
course my protractor is only so accurate
I was kind of estimating but this is not
estimating this is precise it is
approximately equal to 27 degrees
because we were reading our protractor
right but it's far more precise there
just to the nearest degree okay so we
can use this this is really really cool
if you know any of the side
length of a triangle like say you got
this triangle here you got these side
legs you can work out the angles okay so
let me give you an example question
here's one so you've got a triangle like
so okay and you've got a right angle
over here a 1215 and then they call this
angle down here theta okay now we're
going to use one of the three trig
ratios to work out what this angle theta
is okay so what we can do is we can say
write out soft
Toa and we'll refer to that in a second
now which which sides do I have here
when I look from the vantage point of
theta well 15 is the hypotenuse because
it's the longest side and it's opposite
the right angle so this is always the
hypotenuse whichever angle we've got
this 12 is opposite the theta
right you can see it's its opposite
there sits facing so this is the
opposite side so then I have to think
okay out of these three trig ratios sine
cos 10 which one of them which one of
these ratios compares the opposite side
with the hypotenuse Oh an H and the
answer is its side you can see it's got
opposite and hypotenuse there so I can
write that sine theta it's this angle
here is opposite on hypotenuse okay
which in this case is 12 over 15 so I
can simplify that a little bit because
12 over 15 has a common factor of 3 so
there's going to be 4 over 5 yeah so
what I do now is I reach for my
calculator just like before we used Tan
inverse in this case because we're
trying to find out this angle in this
triangle we can say theta is sine
inverse of 4/5
so you reach me calculator there's sine
inverse just above the sine button and I
can say it shift sign which gives me
sine inverse and then I can put in 4/5
which gives me fifty three point one
three etc degrees okay so I'll just
round it off to the nearest degree okay
so this is really cool whichever sides
we've got we can always match them up to
one of the trig ratios and we can use
that to find out any of the angles in
the Triangle